à quoi elle va ou huawei
elle est issue vous avez noir mais
celui-ci vous aussi gêna ici à là parce
que la machine c'est comme en amour peu
ses cours vu ses boutiques célèbre
douala et donc aux donc c'est une corde
ces foules il me fait penser à jean
michel parce que très mou bien entendu
c'est une corde à noeuds saint michel
mais là il y en a bu l'on se pose est
donc voilà et donc cette corde
je vais m'entraîner pour le week-end
puisque je vous rappelle que je suis
marié je vais essayer essayez de la
régie diffon c'est un bon entraînement
pour ses rimes pour demain matin et
dimanche matin
alors monsieur parce que nous avons une
vie amoureuse le week-end comme tous les
ans
[Applaudissements]
avec votre mari alain serrie je vous
jure je vous jure que plusieurs canons
la porte d'entrée
voilà aussi je regardais je vais skier
essayé mais qu'elle touche et alain
alain et une tu ne sais pas tout d'après
l'envoyé ont gardé même du pack ce
propos regardez non regardez aux
mondiaux voyez on y arrive et là je
boucle sa saison si je regardais away
est elle encore un excellent cndd mime
[Applaudissements]
ces plaisirs serez sûr
vous allez vraiment faire mal à passer
très rapidement
mais non on est entre nous non mais vous
savez moi une fois par week-end ça me
suffit à olemps maxime maxime est ce que
c'est possible de remettre le corps
normalement ou pas de le cas le corps
les miens qui avait le truc